so hey everybody had a little Mike
trouble on this one sound quality is not
going to be up to usual standard sorry
maybe so when the longest-running
superhero in comics with the best known
origin of any character in the medium so
yeah of course we should do a new origin
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks I gotta talk comics this time
been a little bit uh on that this is a
patreon sponsored review and I was
commissioned to take a look at Superman
birth right now this as my intro implied
is a retelling of the origin of the Man
of Steel they've got it right there on
the cover Mark Waid was the writer on
this and for that reason alone people
should realize that I was being a little
bit facetious because yeah Superman
doesn't really need his origin retold or
rather didn't need it retold in 2004
when this thing was published but Mark
Waid at least as much Mark Waid as I've
read I first slightly mixed things about
his recent output but but as far as the
stuff that I've read from him can is
concerned I don't think the guy knows
how to write a bad comic book script so
yeah even though this is very
well-trodden ground it's really really
well done the I think the key thing if
this is something that Mark Waid is very
good at he doesn't reinvent the wheel he
doesn't do this drastic recreation this
major shift I put his stamp on it he
sticks to the bones and the fundamentals
of the story that we all know just
brings it up to speed he did a similar
thing with the Fantastic Four kind of
around the same time actually I think
guess a little bit before this where he
just cut down to the core of those
characters in produce
a great book and he does the same with
the script for this book so this is an
Origin we're covering the escape of
Superman from Krypton his we get mostly
flashbacks to his initial raising in
Smallville with monpa Kent in this
version as in some versions he did
actually grow up and know Lex Luthor
when they were younger in about
highschool age he gets into you know
Superman Clark Kent gets into journalism
moves to Metropolis starts working for
the Daily Planet the usual stuff occurs
Lex Luthor is there the to immediately
start butting heads and we're off to the
races like I said there's nothing that's
a big fundamental change there's nothing
that you would say oh that's how he made
it different it is brought up to what
was at the time of publication current
day so the flashbacks retro actively
take place in this 80s
I guess 70s 80s and the all the stuff
set and the present was present for that
point in time the modern day so he goes
to work at the Daily Planet but it is a
combination printed newspaper and
website so there's that acknowledgement
of where things were trending and
shifting at the time and Mark Waid has a
very good understanding of Clark Kent
and as far as the the title goes
birthright this is a version where he at
least to the memory of things that I've
read where Superman knows the least
about his origins he doesn't know the
name of the planet he came from he
doesn't know why he was sent off of it
he cannot speak Kryptonian he's got
basically a tablet of data but he
doesn't speak the language so we can't
understand most of it he has images and
sounds and voices but he doesn't know
who he's looking out wait how long ago
any of this
was what any of it means so he's lacking
a lot of the context so there's a lot
more emphasis on how he was raised by
mom pav Kent which is kind of nice
because I feel like especially in more
recent times there's been a lot more
emphasis on his alienness and I feel
like this version really puts a lot of
emphasis on the way that he was raised
and that the homegrown heroism of him so
that's that's a really nice touch this
Lex Luthor that what I'm gonna say
something that is gonna sound like an
insult but I mean it well I would not be
surprised to find out that Jesse
Eisenberg's take on Lex Luthor for
Batman V Superman took some inspiration
from the version of Lex Luthor we get in
this now again that might sound like an
assault cuz that wasn't a very good take
on Lex Luthor but the thing is reading
this basically showed me how that sort
of you know not big business mobile
necessarily but that sort of snarky tech
genius you know superiority inferiority
mesh complex smartest guy in the room
cannot stand how dumb everyone around
him is kind of interpretation of Lex
Luthor could be made to work I feel like
that was the foundation that Jesse
Eisenberg was trying to build on what he
created didn't work though to be fair
almost nothing in that movie really
works but reading this it's like oh
that's how it could have been done to
actually function it okay
and also this loop this Lex Luthor is a
lot more emotionally volatile especially
in the in the flashbacks that we get to
him as a teenager we had a much better
sense of sort of how long he's been
really pretty dang damaged and the thing
that I enjoy about that is the men just
do it without turning into you know
whiney which was the problem in say the
recent animated release of death of
Superman
the supermen at least problems with that
characterization so it's very that's
very well done stuff and the
relationships between everybody at the
daily planning is a lot of fun Perry
White and and Lois and Jimmy
it's the dynamic is it it's all built up
and it's just the right balance because
obviously we know these characters we
know they're done be closed and
everything so it would have been easy
for mark Wayne to just be like and he's
here are these characters you know
they're gonna get along let's just
pretend like they always have no he does
take the time to establish how these
reporters get built but it also doesn't
sing so much time into it where we're
going yeah we know we know we know he
really does look really great job
balancing that now for all the praise
I've now heaped on this thing you may
have picked up a word I've kept using
whenever I say something nice and that
is the word script because the arced by
one Lionel Francis you is a GUI as hell
the art in this thing is hideous I
cannot think of another comic or graphic
novel that I have read with a bigger
discrepancy between the quality of the
written word the quality of the script
and the quality of the art it is just so
far off I've read plenty of stuff lousy
art but usually it was scripts that
weren't that good either or at best were
inoffensive scripts and then the art
made it bad this is a great script that
still makes for a good story but it is
dragged from great to good because the
art is just hideous
like okay this is the very first image
we get of Lois Lane I wish I was kidding
and before anyone jumps to the idea like
oh he just can't draw Lois no it's not
just her like this
this is Lex Luthor in one image yeah
this stuff is all over the place and
look I was around in the early 2000s I
was still picking up comics every now
and then at that point some of the
ugliness of this is indicative of the
art style of the time but even by the
standards as some of the stuff that was
just the way things are being drawn at
that point I don't think this is fun
ugly even trying to grade on the curve
of what the early 2000s art was like I'm
not gonna say there's no good art in it
every now and then you get a decent hero
shot of you know one of the main
characters but anything that is not
carefully crafted as a primary image
like this is meant to be like a VI
iconic image of Superman flying or Lex
Luthor and the shadows or you know
Superman smashing the car into the thing
like me out to cover the very first book
or what have youd like if it's not that
it's just
unappealing and ugly I keep coming back
to that word the art is really ugly and
also at times difficult to follow that
is less of a problem than just the
inherent hitting hideousness of it but
there are definitely times where I was
like I'm sorry what happened but I
picked up on it cuz the script made it
clear enough but the art I'm like home
go what are you doing I get it's not
good at all
and it's really infuriating because it
is such a good script this is such a
good retelling and it and it does not
leave any of the iconography behind I
mentioned you know they managed to work
in Superman smashing the the car into
the rock like the original cover of the
very first issue of Action Comics that
helped by 2004 boom boots were a
complete and utter anachronism they
still find a way to have a nod to the
changing in a phone booth without having
a phone booth there cuz there wouldn't
have been in a major metropolitan
at that point in time so these things
are there and we get the little nods the
knowledge means there's a lot of really
interesting amounts of detail put into
how Clark you know studies acting you
know to slouchin you know really not be
noticed and you know the the whole thing
with the glasses there's actually a
wonderful little line because my Kent
puts the glasses on him to dull the
color of his eyes she's like you have
some of the most brilliantly blue eyes
that have ever existed anywhere they are
striking and they are memorable here
puts these incredibly strong
prescription glasses on him and they
dull the eye color a little bit it's
just these little acknowledgments of the
things that we know are iconic to
Superman like the glasses like the
slouch like the phone booths like the
carvings and then so many more things
that I can even think to say they're
here and in a way that is sort of
acknowledging that they need a little
bit more explanation than they would
have when they were first introduced but
still recognizing the iconography of it
never making fun of it never me life
isn't that stupid
it's a perfect level of reverence for
the history and the prestige of the
character and everything that he is and
has been in a stood for it's such a good
script that I wish God I wish the art
didn't suck so that's Superman
birthright I do still recommend it for
the script alone but dear God it's not
the worst art I've ever dealt with like
I was buying coming from the 90s I've
seen worse
art than this again it's just the
disconnect of how good the script is
okay so that's where my birthright have
you read this what did you think about
it if you haven't read it do you
personally have a favorite take on the
origin of Superman it can be from the
comics it can be from any movie or
television interpretation whatever is
your favorite drop something
down the comments let's talk about a
bunch of stuff to do like subscribe
patreon it's how this where have you got
sponsored plus it's my birthday this
month so I've got my wish list in the
description down there all that stuff
but you also don't have to do any of it
cuz end of the day folks you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]